like why do you think you always wanted
to do anal on yourself it's gay
why'd you see that because I'm not I was
just yeah I hope I'm not like
you throw that out there yeah they clip
that you know what I mean I'm gay does
it feel good I don't mind I'm supportive
of the LG LG you know what I mean but of
course yeah but it's weird because you
don't let any fingers up there but why
did you keep shoving [__] up your ass
when you were I think at the time right
I didn't have the talent
don't sell yourself
but in my mind I'm like oh these guys
can do Impressions and they're like and
they could do like me sir no one does a
better Connie Chung he's 50 United
States than you I don't know